sixth
Alright.
Oh,
Oh, me de tolo.
Welcome to the stream.
This is actually not a cake.
It's a cinnamon roll,
but you would never know until I told you so.
Ho, ho, ho.
Hello! My lovely senpai! Congratulations for our one month! One month of us being together
forever! Thank you Griffin for the 50! I'm gonna show you something special! I don't know
if you can see it yet but I'm gonna show you something special! It's my hands! Look I even
put the bandages on and the fingies! More accurate hands! I'm very proud of this one! Look at that!
My mummy wrapping hands! Thank you for the two crown on time! One month down!
Eternity to go! Yeah! Wait you have hands? Yeah! See? Hold on! See? Yeah! Here are my hands!
And I have canonically bandages on my hands so I put on the bandages.
There you go! Senpai! Oh it's actually played! I can't! I'm making hearts!
Wow! Wow! This is my cake! It says omedetto!
Oh yeah! You can have a little sniff of the cake! You can't eat it though!
It's a cake! A cinnamon roll is a cake right? Because it's technically a cinnamon roll.
Is it vegan or made with no eggs? It's vegan! It's actually vegan! The cinnamon roll is actually
vegan! So there's no eggs! So I'm safe Senpai! But I also have a bunch of things that I can open up.
Hold on! I'm gonna see if I can eat the cake! The cinnamon roll cake! You'll start seeing it unravel!
Maybe I should have eaten the stuff!
We'll save the cake for later!
Actually I'll eat the cake over here! Away from the camera!
Maybe I should have brought a knife with me!
It's so sweet!
Anyways! Wow! Talking with my mouth full! Today I have some stuff I can open up!
I have these big buttons from Wonderful Precure! I have four of them in total.
I have these magical doraimi little standees that we can open.
I think these are stickers! I have four of them as well! Oh wow! My auto white balance! Not good!
Yeah! And I think they've got candy in them and maybe a sticker!
And then I also have these guys! Which are like big big ass cards! Big cards! I totally got ripped!
Ah! Ripped off though! Careful reflections go high! Don't worry! I am leaning so far away!
I am leaning so far away! The chances of me getting caught may be close to zero!
The bottle focus is losing its mind! Yeah, I know!
I also have... I have nowhere to put this plate!
If we have time, I have these little origami cake shop
thingies that we can make cakes!
Not exactly zero, but I have this on like a really trusty tripod with weights on it!
So it is unlikely to fall over! Yeah! I've tried my best! I've tried my best some
Yeah! Wait here! Yeah!
Yeah! Yeah! Can I do it with the other hand? Yeah! Yeah! I think it's because of the white that it's like
yeah! It's not really good! So yeah! That is the plan for today!
As I eat this delicious cinnamon roll!
It does not like the wrapping! No! It doesn't like the wrapping!
It makes me look a little tan! Even though I know that I'm pretty pale!
Can you have a bite? No!
No! Maybe you can! It's very sweet!
It's very sweet! Oh! And I have my favorite scissors to cut open!
The packages!
This is so funny! Going like this! Going like so far away!
Like all here like this!
So yeah! You guys got all of these for the low low price of staying with me forever!
The special scissors! They're actually my everyday scissors!
Small hands! Who said small hands? You're right!
Senpai! Oh my gosh!
Thank you Riga Tony for the 100! I am so appreciative! Thank you everyone for being so kind to me!
So I don't know what to start with Senpai! Do I eat the cake? Do I open these things for you?
Do I make fake cake origamis and make you eat them?
It's like the only cake you're going to get are these paper ones!
KKSMR!
I don't think it can catch!
Open the things while eating the cake!
This is going to have to go somewhere and it's very hard to find a place to put this!
I do not have that many! I don't have that many room on my table!
Literally I was so worried about anything reflecting!
Or like you see that this space is the space we're working with!
Wait are those wonderful clear cards? These ones I think are stickers!
So they're little stickers here!
These ones are buttons!
So you have your your friendly, your wonderful, and I forgot these too!
Big death spot! No these are already big! Don't worry!
Good evening Mercy! Did you hear about the Magic Ra- Night Ra- Earth announcement?
The wa- the wa announcement!
Sorry I like choked!
Buttons like shirt buttons like...
like...
I call them buttons! Some places call them tin badges!
Some places are not!
Hold on! I'll open it and then we can figure it out together!
And you you can tell me what these...
Oh you're yummy! These are called so they have backing like that!
Yeah look they're pretty big right? Look!
Oh my gosh! Hold on! Wow! Beauty, beauty person! This is terrible!
So we have... they say big! So they're big! I don't have anything for scale for reference!
Maybe like this Vaseline pin is like a scale reference?
A coin? I don't have a coin with me Senpai! I don't have a coin with me!
It's like a yeah like a size of a cookie maybe!
Yeah 75 millimeters!
Ah metal! Metal, metal, metal, metal, metal!
But yeah you have this one! I swear if I have a double I'm gonna cry a little bit!
Scissors for scale! Okay well scissors! These are kind of small scissors though!
These are kind of small scissors so they're not very big! They're like craft scissors!
Uh harmonica size reference!
Thank you Jamdrop for the 133!
Congratulations on achieving so much in one month! Thank you!
Happy one month Mercy! Thank you Metal!
Harmonica! Harmonica reference! What size harmonica? The average size harmonica!
The average size harmonica!
Anyways that's one! This guy over here! Oh shit!
I think I dropped a gum!
No! Give me my gum!
It comes with a free candy!
So that's carried yummy!
Let's open another one!
Here Lillian! Is it just me Senpai? Is the candy any good? I don't know! I'm not eating them yet!
Come on focus! There we go! Here Lillian!
I have joked about saying that she kind of looks like Suisei!
But maybe that's just me!
Green Suisei! And then candy! Sure you can have the candy later!
Shut the fuck up!
Siri decided to pop! Shut the fuck up!
Forgetting beam!
When I said Suisei!
Ahhhh! Ahhhh!
Forgetting beam! No one heard anything right?
Genuinely you guys didn't hear anything! Oh thank freaking goodness!
It's thank freaking goodness!
And then I screamed because it started to say an address!
And I was like!
That's horrifying! Yeah I was like! What the fuck!
Ahhhh! That's never happened before! We aren't gonna call stellar stellar green green stellar stellar right?
How do I? How do I? I literally do not know how to disable it!
Give me a second Senpai!
I feel like my heart just sank!
Give me a second!
We're gonna freeze a little bit and I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna do the setting stuff!
Weeee!
Turn this shit off! Out!
Okay okay okay we're good we're good
We're good we're good
I am so mad!
Okay yeah!
They're both of them together! The cat and her owner!
I'm okay I'm okay!
Look at that! The cat and her owner! And look I have them separate too!
Oh my gosh what's gonna be the last one then?
Candy surprise!
Late matter Ray! Thank you so much for the raid matter! I hope you had a great stream!
Sorry I panicked because of of of that stupid robot! That stupid robot that I hate!
Is that rare? Are those rare? I don't know! Please please let it not be a duplicate!
Duplicate! Duplicate! Duplicate!
Yeah! Yeah! It's got a duplicate! Whoa! We got all four different! Whoa!
Pure wonderful and pure friendly!
Easy clap! Look at those! Look at these these buttons!
See you got the... wow I am not...
Auto balance not happening right now! Hold on!
No that's worse!
Temp high! Temp high!
Is it gonna is it gonna do the the auto? Auto talk? No! Okay congrats on your first month
Kohai! Have some more for the moving fun! We should torch Siri by the way! Yeah we're gonna torture!
There you go! So we got we got we got pure wonderful and pure friendly! Yeah so cute!
I don't know where to put them but they're really cute right?
Candy surprise! Next is these I feel like these are gummies and so we can we can like look at the
gummies and stuff too! Blah blah blah blah blah blah! Do I need scissors for this?
Oh look at that!
It is a card! Oh my gosh look at the back! I get two cards! Oh my gosh I have two cards!
It comes with two cards! I have this one sort of glittery
and this one is also glittery on the back! Cute! Cute! Yummy and friendly!
And okay no gummies! I have gum though! Two pieces of gum to share!
Nothing else is in here right? No good!
I know it's hard to see!
I know it's hard to see! I tried to up the brightness but then the auto balance is like
being being uh really funky wonky! Oh there you can see it more! Yeah!
And then the back has like the information and stuff!
It's like darkness darkness uh blind ink! It's making me look so different!
It's going crazy!
With gum! Gum be gone!
Yummy!
And another cure friendly!
Then on the back as well! Oh look there's like a close-up!
Cure Lillian! Sorry! Not yummy! Lillian! Well I'm dumb!
It's one day blinding stew but with auto balance! Yeah so they're kind of cute right?
I mean like I'm not going to complain they're all cute!
Ah! Blinded! Blinded by the white lie!
Yeah cute! Let's do another one!
Gum!
They're all very sparkly!
And then oh! Yudoha! And I forgot the dog's name already!
Yeah! No dupes! Komugi! Thank you! I was like the dog!
It's like I'm so bad with names! I'm like the dog! The cat owner!
The dog owner! I mean like her name is Inukai! So her!
You're a ho! It's silly saying you're right!
You're right! Cute! And then the back!
Cure Lillian!
And they felt like it's a little information! Cute!
And I got one more Senpai!
Which is funny because the dog is the protagonist! I know! I know!
There's the dog again! Gum! I have so much candy now!
There's the dog! But in here a human form!
And then and then there's the dog! In the cure form! Cure! Wonderful! Wonderful!
For real? Yeah! This is the dog!
This is the dog! The dog has a human form? Yeah! I mean like
where's the other one?
Where is she? Cure Friendly! This one's a cat!
This one's a cat!
But yeah! Here you go Senpai!
Aren't they cute?
No dupes I don't think! Unless I'm blind! Senpai!
Thank you for the late colon s! No dupes yeah! Friendly and Lillian ah human!
Yeah! So these two are the owners! These two are the owners!
She's the owner of Pomugi! And this dog turns into...
Oh where is it? This human right here!
Yeah! No dupes baby!
And then big cards! They're big! So big! Wonderful! Pre-cure! I love the packaging!
All these like pre-cure packaging are so cute!
Where's where's my pair of scissors? I don't want to like force this to open because there's no
no there's no you know I didn't cut the card did I? I would one
cry two cry
See look how big these are! Oh look they've got little hearts!
There she is! There's the dog and her as big your dog!
The back is just is just plain but the front is like this cute little thing.
And what's our candy?
I don't know what this candy is! It's very hard! Is this even candy? It might be a taffy!
It might be a taffy! I don't know it's pretty big right?
Oh yeah! So cute!
Taste test! I will after after my my cakey!
Okay let's go on the next one! I was clumsy! Let's go on the next one!
Making sure it's not there! I would have cried!
Oh look at that! Oh my gosh it's Sui's sake!
Yeah these are huge right?
Oh and they're kind of see-through! See you can see through them! They're translucent!
See they've got the heart! Whoa! Burst!
And taffy! Again I think it's taffy! I don't actually know!
Wait it kind of smells nice! It smells like artificial fruit! I don't know!
Do the senpais love artificial fruit? It's that scent!
No! Senpai! Oh no! We're saved! Slightly different! Slightly different! We're saved!
Thank you darling visipai!
Happy one month! Month of Versa-ry! It's been wonderful so far and I can't wait to see a girl!
Too! I think I need to run down on the pre-cure franchise lore!
Right now it sounds like magical furry girls to me! I need to know what the story is actually is!
Oh doggie really love owner! Want to be with owner! Become magical girl!
Wish granted! Become magical girl! That's it! Saved by the cat! Yeah look how nice this is though!
Oh they've got like the jewels! It's so cute! I almost I almost thought I had a dupe because
can you see why I thought it was a dupe? Because it's the same one!
It's the same! It's the same pulls! I was like oh my gosh! I get a dupe!
I haven't watched pre-cures as Heartcatch! I think the one that I like the most, the latest one,
is Hug the Toe! Oh my goodness! Look! This one's so cute! Look! The dog! The dog again! The owner of the dog!
Owner of the dog!
Cute! This one's really cute!
I think this one's really cute! Like look at that! Look she's making a heart!
I can do that too! Yeah!
But yeah they're making hearts! Yeah cute!
She has a very cute voice so if you watch the anime I think it's on my crunchy roll.
And yeah let's go through all of them! There! Two!
Yeah! And this one's her by herself! It's the same art as this one! The same art but like a close-up and the dog version!
Yeah! Pretty cute!
I have so many candy now!
I have so many candy now and then I have all these stuff so I'm gonna put them somewhere
where they might have a safe home. Next we have whoops! That's a spell!
We have these ones!
So I don't think these come with candy. They're just little acrylic stands so
protection spell! Yeah! My friend gave me that so I keep that around with me.
I'm very...
So we have these little acrylic stands. I don't think they have candy in them but these are magical doremies!
So not Precure but I saw it in stores anyways and they cost me an arm and a leg so
let's see if we get doops!
Yeah!
Yeah! I forget what these... I've watched magical doremie a long time ago so I don't remember their names.
Anna! Okay so there's Anna and you can see the other side with the little stand hole.
What do you do with the duplicates?
I give them to friends?
No!
The first dupe!
The first dupe of the day!
Oh! The luck has run out!
Beer! Precure blast doremies! Okay! There we go! There's doremies!
But we have a dupe! Our first dupe! No!
And then we have this one because this is a little circle.
I haven't watched doremie in a long long time.
It's gotcha! God's heard your slander! I'm a very unlucky person anyways.
Oh my god!
Oh! Oh! That hurt!
Ten pie!
Thank you for the 127! Here's some luck! Love you design mercy! I'm new!
I thought you were a kalimbo! No! Not new!
We have one more set five! Maybe we can be saved! We have one more!
I somehow feel like we did not, we did not get the luck.
But she's very cute!
You know what I do because of this!
It's safe but like still kind of very similar in color wise right?
Momoko! I remember seeing her.
Still different but like look at these dupes! Oh my gosh!
I cost me an arm and a leg! Not gonna lie! These, these cost like
five dollars each I think and I bought them because I was like yeah surprise bags and now I feel like
I've been ripped off!
Who's arm and a leg? For one yeah!
The curse of Gacha! Yeah the curse has become!
Do I have anyone that loves Dora and me? I'll just give them like
at least all the pre cure ones were good! Yeah!
Which one cost five? Yeah! The pre cure ones cost variety of costs!
Thank you boy for the two! You can have my arm and leg!
But we bought gum! Gum gum!
All these taffy things!
And all these candies! Toss them into into the cage like like no big deal!
Eat it all at once! I can't! Look how much how much of my my um my what do you call it? I still have!
Like my cinnamon roll! I haven't even gone through like a bit of it!
This is a lot of sugars and pie!
But yeah! It looks good! Thank you! I'm so sad we got dupes! I also went through that very quickly!
How did you manage to find an egg-free cinnamon roll?
Um it's a place that specializes! Excuse me some pie! It's too sweet!
It specializes in
and um vegan cinnamon rolls! So that's why I was able to get cinnamon rolls without eggs!
Thank you for that 333! Call an ass! No you are the cinnamon roll! No you!
It would be a problem if I can't eat this because mama and papa they hate sweet and decadent things!
So I would still have to be the one to finish it!
Like I would still have to be the one that finishes it!
And the omeletto turned! There it is!
But yeah wow what fatal luck with the with the doré mi stuff huh!
Maybe it'll keep for a few days! I bought these a few hours ago and when I say a few hours ago I mean like
it's like what eight now?
Not eight! Eleven? Oh what! I bought this at like two two p.m.
I'll try to I'll try to eat at least more than more than a nibble!
But yeah it's really it's really sweet! This one is blueberries and strawberry with I think
strawberry jam and a vanilla frosting with powdered sugar and that's a lot of sugar!
Well
I don't mind sweet!
But sometimes it's too sweet you know!
Sugar with a side of sugar! But I thought I thought it looked the cutest!
Like you agree right? It looks super cute! You agree that it looks super cute!
Why? Why? It's half of you guys! I feel like I've just read like a
a good chunk of you are allergic to strawberries!
It is but it's cool! Hi cute though!
Doug! You're looking at me right now! If you demand more than this I'm gonna have to kill you!
You see this cake? You see this? This will be you! Okay!
Okay!
Understood!
I would die a cinnamon roll!
Yes my fork caught it! Understood!
If I had a knife with me I would probably start stabbing this!
Oh!
Look what you made me do! Look what you made me do!
I'm not going to ruin my pair of scissors!
It stuck right in there! Oh yeah it is! I have to eat around it now!
I got a little bit too aggressive! I don't know my own string!
But yeah my scissors are too cute for this! Just watch the scissors afterwards! Shut up!
You don't understand senpai! Scissors! They have one job and they will always stay to that job!
And if you make them do any other job they will dull and they become useless!
And I like! I like!
How about the scissors in my hair? No these are just decorative!
Yeah! Just sharpen them after you wash them? No! Also!
Wow!
These have only one purpose and they are supposed to be hair accessories!
That's it! These scissors in my hair are hair accessories and they will only be!
They will only be hair accessories! How do you take them out?
You can use your imagination!
I was surprised you weren't good with knives! It was one knife! It was a fruit knife and I cut it
on the dull part! The not sharp part!
Oh she really stuck in there!
Fork! Fork free! Fork free! I like mangled it! But fork free! Oh look! Would you senpai! Would you?
Forbidden! Forbidden! Senpai!
What did you do? I unrolled it!
Okay good! Management let me know that nothing was caught!
Sorry I just unravelled it! I just unravelled it to get the fork out!
Because the fork was really stuck in there senpai!
Really stuck in there!
I got icing on my finger!
That's my tissues!
Okay it should be good now!
Where did you put the tissues? Underneath the desk!
Let us look! No!
Sorry this is very sweet so I'm coughing a little bit from the sweetness!
And also choking because I do that!
Come on! Almost lost!
I ate another big piece! We're going through it slowly!
Have you ever had something so sweet senpai? That you're like cough cough!
Can we lick the fork instead? No I just did! Now it has my cooties on it and you can't have it!
Senpai!
Thank you darling! We senpai for the five!
Mercy! Shows the sun must see me when you when me when me when when when when when
and when you and and and would!
I'm okay with cooties!
Also Mercy your hands are so small! Really someone said a long time ago that my hands were big
and I feel like my hands are kind of small!
Like I think they're pretty small!
I think they're pretty small like comparatively I wear
you have a can or something? I don't drink soda!
You have a ruler or a measuring tape?
Oh no! I got frosting!
Frosting on my dress! No!
I don't even know how to like compare it senpai!
I don't think I have scissors! I mean that's scissors! A ruler!
I don't!
Okay well I have a pencil!
A pencil!
My pencil!
Mouse for scale unless it's wired the mouse I have is small so it's a small one!
Also by the way great mouse!
What size pencil? I don't know!
These are like a smaller this is a smaller mouse so it's it's um it's a smaller mouse so
it can fit my hands!
Yeah the mouse the larger one I have would kept on disconnecting so I
okay senpai's generously got me a smaller smaller smaller smaller mouse!
So you do have small hands? Yeah but I don't have a can or anything I don't drink soda you know!
Cool! High please standardize the size of your home appliances so we can better estimate your
stand proportion!
The can badges these are big these are 75 millimeters so
relatively 75 millimeters!
Hydration drink!
Fork is normal size right? Is there not a normal size fork?
Video game case? Oh okay!
Wow this is the switch case!
Mercy is there a reason your hands are covered in bandages? It's canon!
What is that small?
Wait is that small? I don't know I thought switch cases were kind of...
I mean I do wear like
like children's size gloves!
Yeah I have I brought I brought out SMT
Nup gun!
I do yeah I wear like child's size
Gloves!
You have something that has your bank details so we can scale your hand properly? Yeah sure!
This is my my my my funny digits in the front and this is my other digits on the back
and uh yeah
Gotta get those back digits too! Oh yeah!
What's the expiration date?
It's a little blurry I couldn't make the digits out it's okay it's okay you can guess!
Playing cards are usually standardized at would make them much easier to compare!
Do I have playing cards?
No!
Oh maybe I can try to find playing cards it'll be like pretty far away though!
Who's uh who's a nerd? Who's a nerd here? Like maybe maybe a comparison of a haddle!
Haddle! It would be like okay!
Like a haddle! This is like the haddle in me!
So I I'm like I don't know I feel like when you're like a nerd you have like
Senpai!
Uh that's an unscaled model mercy! Well shut up!
Thank you for the dollar tip it's perfectly fine that mercy is small!
It's gonna make it easier for Senpai to carry her home on the wedding!
Oh thank you Senpai! Seriously happy month of
nursery! Mercy you've done amazingly well so far you should be proud of yourself!
Thank you I am very proud of myself! In fact I'm so proud of myself
that I like that mama mama and papa were like did you get paid and I said I did and they were
very happy! And then they were like how much do you make and I said more than what I made
before which was like nothing! And they were very happy to hear that!
At first at first papa was like are you getting scammed? Did they take your money?
Did they not pay you? And I said no no no no no no no no no no Senpai!
Congrats on one month here's to moving out! Thank you Anonymous for the 20!
Above minimum wage let's go!
Honestly like my my parents were like are you getting scammed?
I've heard all these people getting scammed from fake jobs and I was like no I'm not!
Like how much did I make last year? Not much! So little that I didn't have to pay taxes!
Honestly!
Like very little and the threshold is not very high!
But yeah parents were like oh we heard about this it was on the news blah blah blah blah
a bunch of seniors are getting scammed and young people are getting scammed because
of fake job listings and I'm like not gonna lie I've had had fake job listings!
Thank you Eternity for 20 gifted!
We're paying taxes this year! Yeah I am paying taxes!
I am I am paying taxes oh sorry now you're seeing the table shake that's me I got
I'm stimming!
Taxes! It's the worst! I was it was so easy last year because the tax or the the person
I go to taxes for is like literally just went you don't know anything!
And then I went ouch!
Like ouch but also you know!
Like it's sad but like hey no taxes! Yeah like they didn't hold back!
I have to pay my taxes though! I have to do my taxes every year!
But you know when you make like not that much income and they laugh at you but you're just like
Thank you Misaka best for the Mercy Tax!
I've only made a lot of money when I was in school and that was that was when I paid off so much of
I had I got so much grants and scholarships that I owed the government money!
I paid off my entire tuition with that!
I never heard a person laughing at someone well when they saw how much I made they laughed at me yeah!
So like that means I have like no no no student debt but like I other than that yeah!
You have to be pretty smart for that!
And then I became a neat!
And then life was terrible ever since! Just kidding! As soon as I met my senpais I became much happier!
I became much happier!
Honestly honestly I was like really happy honestly so happy that so one month came went by so fast!
Like I honestly was like so excited to meet everyone even before we debuted so but I was like really
worried that like I was like oh I wonder if people will like me I hope they like me they're gonna
have to like me!
Like it was it was like a mix of emotions!
A mix of emotions like please like me!
You have to like me!
That was so sweet!
What a fun!
I'm slowly going through it senpai! I'm slowly going through this cinnamon roll cake!
Be proud of me! I could honestly add something here for like everyone to look at I think!
Here look at the buttons again! Yeah buttons!
Hand badges whatever you call them yeah!
I swear she really does look like Suisei right? She's so she looks like Suisei!
I think it's funny that the like regular form of Cure Friendly is named Errol!
I'm surprised I didn't get any of the I didn't get her and her like regular form!
Yeah!
The buttons remind me of making Ita bags for my sister!
I was always thinking about making an Ita bag but then I I don't have like
a huge fixation that I can justify making one for!
Like seriously this is like oh my gosh! Is it origami time? As soon as I finish this cake I will do the origami!
Can you show us your handwriting? Why? Senpai why do you want to see my handwriting?
Are you gonna do a forgery?
Are you gonna do a forgery? Are you gonna try to forge my handwriting?
No no what?
No not at all! Would you be proud if we did? I think I would cut off your hands!
This tempting is all I would say! I have chicken scratch writing that's all you need to know!
That's all you need to know! Come on what do you take us for Kohai? I take you for a bunch of lousy
Chicker! Tricksters!
Can you write in cursive? I can write in cursive but you're gonna try to forge my signature and that's a big no no!
That's a big no no no! You're such a kidder Senpai!
But yeah my defenses are high and you cannot go past my defenses! I learned internet safety back in grade!
How many? Wait huh how long ago? That's it!
Can we see your sign your name in cursive exactly as it appears in your credit card? No!
Don't out yourself! I'm just I'm like how long ago was that?
Long time ago and then they assumed for the mercy good food slash drink fund oh thank you
Go for the lead!
Internet safety course! I remember! I remember!
One time my school made us go on a field trip to the police station so that we can learn about
internet safety!
I remember that!
There's a very interactive display!
I think they still use that! A field trip? Yeah a field trip!
Do Senpais not not know what field trips are? Has the education system fallen so far that you
can't have field trips anymore?
What did they tell you? Never give your real name out on the internet and don't trust anyone on the
internet!
What's a field trip? Oh come on! You're just we're just pulling my leg now Senpai!
You're just pulling my leg now!
I was taken to a prison for a field trip! Oh my gosh!
Why did they take you to a prison?
Wait why did they take you to a prison?
Like when I went to the police station it was like here's an interactive
um display about internet safety and the the dangers of drunk driving!
Can we take a field trip out of the house? You can take a field trip passed out!
The police station field trip all we looked at were holding cells!
Leadership program huh? They're like we can't afford anything let's go to prison!
You take pictures while we're knocked out right? Yeah! Your field trip is your dreams
and you can explore all you want and then you get waken up again and you're on a operating table
and there's a chainsaw about to cat open your limbs!
Fun! Fun for the whole family! Great trip!
I didn't need that kidney anyways! How much do human how much do body parts go for?
Uh you know no reason! Out of curiosity!
They're asking for a friend! Yeah just like how Senpai's always asked for a friend!
Senpai!
Thank you for the 499 Tupacab Rally Legend 99!
I have no clue why but my teacher said I was gonna end up there so proven I'm wrong about the prison!
Why is your teacher so mean to you?
Skinnies go for 100k to 200k!
A human heart can go for more right?
Skin 10 dollars per inch! Look!
Now you have to re-senpai when you say you're worthless you're actually worth so much!
Look at that! 1,500 per eye!
A heart goes for 500k to 1 mil! It's okay!
Gives cold eye my heart only for her to give it away!
It's for a good cause! For a good cause! You're volunteering!
Volunteering! It's a good civil civic duty? I don't know what those are called right?
But the heart is only for you! Okay!
Just like signing up for a donation when you die!
I'll keep them nice and preserved!
Nice and preserved!
I'll only sell off the bad senpais! The ones that are fake! Senpai! Senpai!
Thank you Anon for the dollar! An internet safety class I never I learned to never send
money to strange ladies on the internet! Definitely funk back class!
Are you calling me strange senpai? Are you calling me strange?
Oh you're right! But shut up!
You're right! But shut up!
Honestly! How rude! I think they taught you some manners too!
Your cage is going to be a bird cage now! Start squawking!
Speaking of! I went to the pet store today! I got senpai's stuff!
It's a surprise!
Hehe! What stuff I want to see? You have to wait for your surprise!
We have new collars? Unfortunately not new collars!
New ping pong paddles! Do they sell that at pet stores?
When is it the surprise? Next week!
Next week!
Next week! And you, you'll see! You'll see! Don't worry!
I can't wait that long! What? Too fricking bad! Hi! Patience is a virtue!
Haha!
New water bowl! Yes sir!
I don't think I can make it that long without a heart! You already took it out! I wasn't ready!
Haha! I wasn't ready! I don't have, I don't have the, the, the body transport thing yet!
Wait, we had water? I always leave you guys water and like a food bowl!
I also change the water every day!
Aren't, aren't I such a nice girlfriend?
Neen water! Food!
You even get to keep your bionicles! It's great! It's great in the basement!
Haha! A cage over your heads! Hammers! What more could you want?
Is it filtered water or tap water? Um, filtered?
Haha! Just comfy!
Can I get a cat fountain? I like my water with the illusion of freshness!
That's kind of expensive! We're gonna have to like...
Can we wage war against the neighbor's basement? No! I like my neighbors sort of!
Cage larger than a New York, New York City apartment! How small is it in New York?
Wait, is it as small as the Japanese ones?
Probably!
Ah!
Smaller, seriously?
Is it coffin rooms? Not even like... Okay, I've seen like the...
What do you call it?
Capsule hotels and then some of those capsule hotels were converted into like kind of miniature homes.
Haha!
Nightmare in actual apartments in the mini apartments!
Wow! Okay!
So what I'm hearing is it's terrible!
I hear New York has good food, though! Does that make up for the size?
Does it taste really worth it? Absolutely not!
No, no, no! New York has big city rats!
Wait, inflation?
Sorry, wrong inflation!
Price inflation! Wow!
He's joke!
Okay, I need some water now! I laughed too hard on my own joke!
Also, it's like a bite left, Senpai! Look, just a bite left!
I eat so slowly! I'm so sorry! I eat so slowly! It's because I'm yapping!
I'm yapping! I'm yapping while I'm eating!
For us?
I'm surprised you can eat something that sweet! It's slowly, but I'm doing it!
Ah, open wide! Here comes the choo choo train!
Chaka chaka chaka chaka choo choo!
I don't even know what I'm doing anymore!
You didn't waste the last bite with anything, did you? Nothing but love!
Haha!
Regretting your life choices? I don't regret anything!
Except for that one thing, and that other thing, and that other thing, and that one other thing,
and the thing I did yesterday, and the thing I did last week.
Other than that, I regret nothing! What is love a euphemism for?
Use your imagination, Senpai!
Welcome, Raiders!
Welcome to the stream, Bettybeats!
Beatcuper Kendra Bratton! Welcome to the stream!
Welcome, Raiders Mothray! Welcome, welcome, welcome to the stream!
Hello, my name is Mercy Maldives from Via Lore's Indul- First Gen Indulged!
I am your- your dorky yandere! Welcome to my basement!
We're celebrating our one-month celebration today. I'm in the middle of eating um my
cinnamon roll, and I finished opening my stuff. I'm pretty cute, merch stuff!
And like some more pretty cute blind bag stuff that we we got. These are really cute!
And I'm doing a hand cam. Oh my gosh, see? I already got like frosting on my- on my- on my- on my- on my gloves.
Well, welcome, welcome, welcome! How was your stream?
Sorry, I'm coughing so much. The cinnamon roll is very-
Very, very, very sweet.
Thank you B-Dest for the 199 Super Chat Pre-Cure Merch needs more cowbell. I don't have a cowbell.
Good, I suffered through bloodborne for six hours. Six hours! Wow, you are a
endurance streamer! Almost as- endurance as-
Fraune! Who's also a gen main of mine who's streamed for long hours?
Wow!
Drone cowbell fun when? I actually went to a store and I saw a cowbell and then I said,
huh, should I pick one of those up for like ASMR streams? And then I rang and I was like,
I don't think this is a very pleasant sound.
I don't think this is a very pleasant sound for like anyone to listen to.
It'll be like, dong dong dong dong dong dong dong. But I had the chance.
I had the chance to get one.
One hour cowbell.
You're a mancy.
But I got some other things for ASMR-er.
I went around for like a while trying to find some nice ASMR stuff and then I would like put it to
my ear and then sometimes the staff's like, oh, can I help you with anything? Oh, why are you looking
for your things that make nice sounds? And I was like, uh, uh, I'm a- I'm a Foley artist. I'm a Foley
artist. I'm recording sound. Yeah.
I hate it when they ask questions.
I'm audio engineer.
Yeah, I'm a Foley artist, you know, like when they record like sound effects. Yeah.
I'm a farmer.
Should I plug your Patreon? No. Wait, I should plug my Patreon though.
After I finish this.
This is safe for work. I had this. Hold on. Actually, I can do it now.
This is my, my safe for work stream.
Patreon schedule.
The mini golf. Three whole mini golf. First one.
We're tied up with one hand free. Wow. Questioning wiper fluid choices.
And rearranging tables with me.
Please be 18 plus.
These tables aren't going to table themselves. Oh boy.
Mini golf. You get there. Wait, this isn't mini golf.
No worries. My chat that came in here are all 18 and other.
Good.
Good. In case you know, in case you know, if you do know how wink, wait,
I'm winking, but I have an eye patch on. So it looks like I'm blinking.
If, if you are, if you don't know, Teehee.
Oh.
Play mini golf. Oh.
Eye patch is perfect cover for not being able to wink. I can wink.
I just choose not to take off my eye patch.
You can still play mini golf after probably. I love cheating and golf though.
I love cheating and golf. Nobody's watching. Kick the ball in.
Oh, look over there. Smash him with the club.
She loves cheating. It's over. Why are you making up some pie? I just said in mini golf.
Golf with friends would be so fun though. Look over there.
He's into NTR. NTR, NTR this, NTR that. Wow. Everyone's so obsessed with NTR.
Thank you for the five second. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yacht club. Wow. I couldn't even
read for a second. I guess my favorite VTuber mercenary modesty. What the heck?
Where is he? Modest. Modest nuts.
Yandere for hire. I come in with my cinnamon roll scissors and
attack my target.
Oh my gosh. I haven't even finished this fight.
She made it there. Scissors for cinnamon roll. The character. The character's in my roll.
Look at that. Cute.
Cute. I also don't like how this auto color balance is dying on me.
It won't show you the goods. It's like turning so dark.
I like, I like, I generally like anything cute.
Camera's so wacky. I haven't set this up in a long time.
I feel like my favorite character, if I had to go for Sanrio, is like Pom Pom Pudding.
Look, it's so dark now. See? It's like, oh, I need to balance with, why are you like this?
No. Probably need something dark to like, balance it out.
Ah, that's better. Oh, it's, it is, it's having a nightmare though.
Oh, professional streamer, Mercy Modees.
Turn on the lights. It is on. It is on.
See? If I do this. Oh, you can see frosting on my glove. Anyway, if I do this, this is the regular light.
This is the regular light.
And if I move away, it suddenly gets darker for some reason. I guess it's trying to,
wait, hold on, let me check my, my web. Oh, I see.
The, no, go back, go back, go back. All the exposure is messed.
Stay, stay.
No.
Yeah, the camera only wants to see my hands.
The camera only, only wants to see my hands. It only has eyes for me.
Usually it doesn't get like this, but I'm spending finicky today.
Keep my hand on the table.
Never mind. I need, I need my other. I need this hand to eat.
I just want to focus on me, Mercy Modees.
I think it's dimming because of the reflections from the ceiling light.
You can, you can see the, the kind of like my lights. Actually, this is the camera.
It might be too bright. Hold on.
Thank you, Bethes for the 199 Supercat.
My camera seems handy. Yeah, hold on, let me adjust some stuff. Maybe it will
adjust the lighting and the temperature.
Now let's do cool temperature.
Maybe it will work more. There, lights have been dimmed.
There you go. Look, look at me, Senpai. I just adjusted the lights.
This is how much work I put into a stream sometimes.
Slightly brighter. Yeah. Otherwise, if I go any lower, it's just gonna be like
pretty much nothing, but hey, yellow light.
Maybe I can cool it down even. Nah, doesn't make a difference.
I see it's so, it's such a yellow light, otherwise.
There they are.
Woo! Thank you, Senpai, for the fix.
Pretty cute.
Let's get this one out. It's cuter.
Yeah, cuter.
It's actually darker. The camera just makes it look brighter.
Thanks for the $4.99. This is her super chat. Well, then I'm not gonna read the rest.
Boom.
Am I okay? This, this cake, it's very sweet. And because it's so sweet, I'm coughing because
I'm choking on it.
Sorry about coughing a lot, though.
Oh, there's a little bit more, Senpai.
It's very sweet. It's like, it's vanilla frosting with strawberries, blueberries,
and powdered sugar. I think the powdered sugar
makes it too sweet.
It's done!
It's done! I'm free!
It took forever, but I did it.
Okay, let me go through my child stuff. And maybe we can finally do the cake origami.
Let me just move all these guys over.
Sorry about the delay. I was like, yeah, cake!
It was one of those things, you know?
There we go.
The duality of cake. So we have kind of like a little folding book. Oh, there's like tons of them.
That's nice. There's like lots of them. Now the issue is, are there instructions?
Because I might have to just, you know, oh, instructions?
I should have seen this coming that it was in Japanese!
Oh, I should have figured this out. I did say I would fail at this.
Okay, so let's start with this cake. I'm pretty sure there should be other
pieces too. Yes, yes, I see some. Assism! Then we have strawberry.
Thank goodness for pictures. Where would I be without them? Probably nowhere.
Okay, I think that's all I need. See, I have like frosting on here.
Okay, instructions.
Hope it's pretty easy to make. Well, I'm going to follow the instructions with the scissors,
and I'm going to cut them.
I'm using the camera.
Okay, just like gunpla, except for worse, maybe?
Hmm.
Paper. Scissors! Rock!
Which way is the direction?
Scissors? Cut, cut, cut. Cut, cut, cut. I said I would fail at this.
I bought it and I was like, oh, this, oh, this one's cheaper. I wonder why it's cheaper.
I should have figured that it was because it was harder.
Okay, here is the strawberry. Okay.
We'll see the instructions for the strawberries. Okay, hold it like this.
Hold it like this.
Hold it over here. Okay. Okay, okay, we got this. Probably.
This would make a good ASMR stream. You're in luck, this is the ASMR stream.
Okay, okay, I think I know what they're saying. Yes, yes, okay.
Hold it like this. I'm on this instruction over here that you cannot see this one.
This one goes over here. This one goes the same way, I'm assuming.
And then you can have a triangle. Yeah.
I think, yeah. Wow, I am not dexterous at all. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay.
What does this mean? Okay, so it's asking me, hold it.
Like what?
Oh, I see it now. I see it now.
And then we fold it this way. Yeah.
So we're on this instruction now, and then we're probably going to go on the same
thing for the other side. Yeah. Yeah, I got it.
It's not the best, but I got it.
Okay, let's see what else they got. I'm on.
Nine.
Yeah.
And then the other side. Same thing, I think.
Wait, I think, oh, this is hard with bandaged hands.
Can I read it? Oh, I can read it, but I don't know the words.
I think.
Oh, that's crunchy looking. I played myself a little bit with the band-aids.
Yeah. I really wanted to impress my senpais and be like, hey, look at me. I'm cosplaying myself.
Yeah.
I'm a bit of a fool. Admittingly, I'm a bit of a fool for that.
Oh my gosh. What does this mean? Give me a second.
Am I still here? It said OBS disconnected.
Welcome back. Okay, it buffered. Okay, it did some funky thing. Yeah, we're here again.
Wow. Okay.
Instructions a little hard when it's just pictures.
When it's just pictures, it's a little hard.
I think I somehow have it.
Oh, tucking it in is really hard. Tucking it in is really hard. Look at that. Look at that fold.
Isn't it neat? Don't you think that my collection is complete?
Don't you say I'm a girl? Girl to hands? Everything!
Ah, shit, I un-tucked it.
Get in there. Yeah. Yeah, look at that.
Great fold.
This one.
And then this one as well. Then they fold.
They fold in.
Yeah, fold in here.
Come on.
Give me a second. I'm over here.
Give me a second. I'm trying to fix. I'm trying to tuck it into the slit.
I'm trying to tuck it into the slit. It's not wanting to tuck. It's way in.
The dexterity. I don't have it.
This is what happens when your fingers are bandaged.
Your fingers are bandaged and you thought this was a great idea because you wanted to impress your
senpai's. But here it is. I cannot tuck.
This is where it falters and suffers for the art.
Where they are, I tucked one side and I was very proud of it but now this side won't tuck.
It's tough being an artiste.
And then as I can see here is that I can, once it tucks, I can push the bottom
a bit and then it makes it a strawberry and I'm just like,
oh, shit.
I am not the queen of tuck. I have found out I am not the queen of tuck.
Right now the tucking game is not there. It is weak. It is gone. It is...
Yeah.
Why was it easy to tuck on the other side but not this side?
Any of my scissors? Do I need my scissors to be like, get in there?
I need a pot that I'm more expensive on.
Well, it's sort of a strawberry.
I don't think this is real. I don't think this is real.
You can see the pattern on it so it's supposed to puff out at the sides
if I could have tucked it in and then stands up like that. So I applied.
I tried and I failed. Oh, I found some. Okay, hold on.
Which way is it floating? Okay, okay, I see something. I see something. I see some more
instructions. Fold this side. Yeah. Then we fold this side over.
This is the cake. This is the brown part of cake. Triangular part of cake. Yeah.
The slice part. Yeah.
Hold on.
Instructions.
There are two of them that I'm supposed to do.
Oh yeah, there is two of them I'm supposed to do.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
Fold this one. Then we fold this one the same way.
Fold one side down.
Other side also down. Wow, paper hard. I used to do like origami as a kid. I was so good at it.
And now look at me. Terrible at it.
And it says here to slide this vision around this part.
I don't think I did this right. I think this is the other way around. I think it's the other way
around. I think this is supposed to be in here. And then this part is supposed to be folded over
like this. Yeah.
And this part is supposed to fold over like this.
And then
it's supposed to. Oh, I see it now. I see it now, Senpai.
I think you're supposed to slip it in here. It's supposed to slip in here.
Look, look the triangle part. It's popping out, but it's fine.
Yeah, let's go. We got it. Cake piece.
I understood the assignment.
Now I need a white sheet now because we got a bunch of those.
Yeah, we need this sheet now. This one says to fold it in half.
That's not a very good half, but you.
And then
and I think
Sorry, give me a second Senpai. I'm kind of dumb.
Okay, I think I open it again and fold it
this way.
Okay, fold it this way.
And then we fold it this way again.
And then it looks like it's telling me to unfold it again
and do it smaller scale. Okay, let's see how this works.
And then fold it like this.
Oh, paper.
If only I was more dexterous.
Then I could totally make this look better, but as far as Senpais know, I'm still pretty clumsy.
Okay, now it's telling me to take this part and fold it like this. Okay.
No, that's wrong. I think. No, that's right. That's right. I'm just being weird.
And then fold this
this way.
And fold this
And then fold it. Okay. Okay, confuse. This way.
I think that's too big.
I think that's too big, but it's supposed to like...
Wait, hold on.
Okay, so I folded it
this way.
Yes, and I folded it.
Then we fold it
this way. Oh, okay. I see it. I see it now. I see it now.
Then we fold it this way. Huh. I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it.
And then I think Senpai.
Then we got it this way.
Thank you for the five, Charlie Spur.
Kolei, stop hurting your hands, but the scissors down. That's what it looks like. I'm holding scissors.
Oh my gosh, I got it. I think I got it. Oh, Senpai.
I think I got it. It's not the greatest looking thing, but I think I got it.
I just need to figure out what they did for this last part because now I'm confused.
This part with the eight right here, I'm like, okay, now what did you do?
There's my, there's my first piece of the cake. There's my really shitty strawberry that I couldn't
talk. So like, what did they do?
What did they do? I think they did this.
I think that's what they did. They like folded this part in.
But then it doesn't fit here unless
it doesn't fit here. It's supposed to like fell on top. I'm like, wait, this is too big.
Was I supposed to make a smaller? Was I supposed to make a smaller one? And then it just,
wait, was there like other smaller ones? Hold on. Did I get the wrong paper?
Was I supposed to cut it smaller?
When I said I would fail, I meant it.
I'm supposed to go up here. I think I was supposed to cut it smaller.
Oh boy. I think I was supposed to cut it smaller and then I was supposed to slide in.
I was supposed to slide in because you can kind of see where the folds were supposed to go
in order to go into here. And then after that you get like the strawberry on top.
And then I...
We can still work with this. We can still work with this. This can still be saved, I think.
Give me a second, Senpai.
This can still be saved. This can still be saved.
It's just a cake with a lot of frosting. This can still be saved. I'm going to pretend
that I didn't mess up and we're going to force our way in. We're going to force our way in.
We're going to force it.
Ta-da! Just shove it in there!
And then the strawberry cake.
Look! It's a strawberry cake! Yeah! Great job, me!
Wow, it looks so tan. Oh, there it is. There's my...
But yeah, it was supposed to like be flat here and then it was supposed to sit on top.
It was saved! Barely. Oh, I broke it. It was saved! And then it wasn't saved.
Wait, I got this. I got this. I can fix this.
Our cake! No! No, Senpai! I gotta make my Senpai happy! Get in there!
Don't worry, it's just...
Yeah, I don't have tape. I'm sorry, I don't have a tape. But we did it!
Delicious for Senpai, especially from me!
Here, hold on. I'll turn it to the side. It'll look kind of cuter.
It's sort of cute.
It looks great from above, sort of.
Don't look at the sides. Don't look behind it. Don't look at anywhere else.
I forced it in.
It's scuffed with the love, with my love. It's fine. Look at that cake.
The strawberry fell off. It's okay. Okay.
The cake! Your wonderful cake! Oh, my love! Yeah!
Oh, gosh. They're teaching me more ways to make other cakes.
Bro.
Yeah, I did it!
It was forced in.
We'll get this next time.
Look, I can make so many strawberries!
That's amazing! Look at that! Oh, fuck.
Yeah, that's amazing! Look at that! Perfect!
It'll be on like a cute little plate and everything. And you can have the strawberry.
You can have the best part. The strawberry, Senpai.
Have the best part. The part that... Actually, that's not a good looking part here.
Yeah, this part looks better. No, it looks...
Yeah! Fantastic!
Praise me! Praise me! Look at this cake that I made for you with love and paper!
Origami is not for me.
This is not a hobby that I particularly find stimulating.
It's our cake. Since you didn't have any cake, you can have this paper cake.
But if you close your eyes and maybe... Maybe if you narrow your eyes and blur a little bit,
it looks like a real cake.
Oh, boy.
It is blurry enough. There.
Just add some sugar and there you go!
It is very cake. Uh, yeah. Great. Delicious.
Happy one-month anniversary, Kui. Looking forward to many more.
I hope this is enough to cover for the lovely cake you made.
Thank you, Senpai, for the hundred!
It is more than enough. It is more than enough for the cake that I just made.
Thank you. Senpai's up. It's so kind to me.
I would feed it, but it's falling apart. There. It's so cake. Don't look underneath.
It's so cake.
You know, like I needed glue or something to make it like, oh, boom, cake.
Yeah, great stuff. Peace, peace, peace, peace, peace.
Boneless!
I asked for that cake. Boneless!
Oh, my gosh. When I was a kid, I loved folding paper because, um, wow.
You know what? I'm going to use Trauma Dump on you, Senpai.
When I was a kid, uh, for the longest time, I could not afford...
I could not afford Barbies. So we had paper dolls.
And I would cut out our puncture.
The puncture, like, pop out the doll dresses.
I would just dress up the dolls using the paper.
Because that was before I was able to have Barbies or anything, right?
So most of my toys were paper.
Oops.
Yeah, we... I just used what I had.
The paper dolls were very cheap.
Like, you could get a book with these, like, little, slightly cardboard-ish,
cardboard-adjacent, um, paper dolls, and then I would take...
And then it's like furniture for all paper too.
So you would have to, like, assemble the, like, the, like, furniture and the beds
with, like, the paper.
So yeah, I'm like, wow. This is return to form, but as a kid,
I think I would have done a better job.
That's the sad part, is that I think I would have done a much better job.
Ugh.
I don't know if I want to torture some pies the strawberry fell off.
I don't know if I want to torture some pies with another cake.
Oh, that made a funny sound. It made a door-ing sound.
Second try, let's go!
Mmm.
Luzukashi.
I see. This is, it's hard.
I see it's hard. Look at that. Four-star difficulty.
Yeah, these are some fancy-ass cakes, huh? See, this is what the one I was supposed to make you look like.
Next one in the instructions was this one.
And then...
This one looks like the easiest, but I also don't trust myself to make it easy.
Mmm.
Yeah.
We made something, some pie.
Hold on, let me check. Which instructions belong where?
I think...
Yeah, it's this one. This is the instruction. Okay.
There's the star. Okay. I can do it again!
Probably.
Haven't.
My favorite saying.
There I go.
Yeah. Almost doesn't have.
And then, I'll pince it up, and then folds again. Up here it looks like.
Yeah, to this line.
And then this goes where?
Oh, okay. So, so, so, so, so. Okay, I see it, I see it. This one goes, uh...
I think...
Back at the line that we went to before.
It had two papers stuck!
It has two papers stuck to it! I accidentally folded! Folded this one!
Ah!
Okay, okay.
I got this Senpai. I got this.
And then we fold down this line.
Yes, I have it! I have it!
I got it. Okay, and then this side.
Yes, yes. Okay, then we fold this side. Yes. Okay, I'm seeing it. I understand it.
Yes.
I see it. I understand. I'm getting... I'm picking up what they're putting down.
I can't even see.
Yes, yes, yes.
I see it. I see it.
Yes, yes, okay.
We folded that. Then we fold this. Yes, I'm seeing it. It's working!
Ah-ha-ha-ha!
We fold it again. Yes!
Oh-ho! Oh-ho!
Oh-ho! Oh-ho! Oh-ho! Oh-ho!
Look, there's like a little tuck in there. Okay.
Now what?
Ha! Oh, we unfold it now. Okay, understood. We unfold it.
Like that. Okay.
We unfold it again. And then...
Looks like we fold it like this. Oh! Okay, look. I'm starting to get it, Senpai.
Okay, so, so, so, so.
Okay. We did that. Now on this side.
What are they asking me to do?
Okay, okay. Wait, I got it. I got it. Okay, so they're asking me to fold this again.
Yes. I think.
I think.
Wait, hold on. Okay, I got that part. Yeah, I got that part. Yeah.
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay. I think I got it. I think I got it.
I think I got it. I think I got it. I think I got it. I'll let you know if I don't got it.
Which might be very soon.
I don't got it. Oh, wait. No, I got it.
We're back. We're back. We're back.
Wait, I misunderstood one of the assignments. And then now I'm back to understanding the
assignment sort of. I think.
Yes.
Yes. Okay. No, I got the assignment now.
Okay. Now that makes more sense.
Yes, that makes more sense.
Does it make more sense?
Okay.
Okay, wait. Like I said, do this. Okay, okay. Now, hold this up. Okay, okay.
Okay. Okay, now it looks like this. Okay, okay. Now we hold it to this line.
Okay. Now we hold it to this line. Okay.
And then
touch here, touch here.
Oh, wait. I'm getting somewhere. I'm getting somewhere.
Oh, oh, oh, wait, wait. Am I truly believing? Am I truly understanding the assignment?
Am I truly understanding the assignment?
Oh, oh, oh.
It's terrible, but I somewhat got it. It looks terrible, but I somewhat got it.
It's supposed to look like a box. I think I'm supposed to pinch the side so it like
flattens out or something. I don't know how they did that. Oh, no.
Oh.
This pulls cheated chocolate. I got to a point and then it's like, oh, okay. Yeah.
I got to a point where it's like, okay, now I'm just lost.
Now it's a brownie.
There it is. I somewhat folded it correctly.
I think the up here is not as square as I was hoping it to be, but I was
using instructions as it was well instructed.
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom. Here you go, Senpai. You can have this delicious cake. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. It's supposed to put like a sticker here for like the garnish.
Then here's my other cake that is falling apart. That's okay. It's falling apart. That's okay.
Just like all of us are.
And the strawberry that I was unable to make immaculate.
Yeah, cake.
Two cakes.
And then we'll just copy and paste and all Senpais can have more than one cake.
I don't know how they made it a square though. That's my mystery. I'm like, I got this far.
And I got it to a brownie.
Efficiency. You can eat it now like a sandwich.
Yeah, you can see the frosting.
It's like instructions unclear. My box thing looks flat and roundish.
Ah, the strawberry! Okay, now save.
I think I'm going to stop there, Senpais.
As much as I want to continue making you delicious paper cakes. I am terrible at it.
Did you have fun today? I know most of it was me eating a cake.
Look, we have our strawberry cake and
and our brownie.
And then I started making mistakes after mistakes.
Happy one month, look.
Happy one month, Senpai. And hopefully a lot more together.
You can't leave me now, okay? I've shared, I've shared my mistakes and my clumsiness with you.
Okay, you have to, you have to stay now.
I showed you my cake, please respond.
It's like you're all trapped here. Look, I made this ugly cake for you and I made this slightly
better cake for you.
Once we'll celebrate again when it's maybe five months and a year, no wait six months,
half year. I'll do our half year celebration and maybe birthday celebrations and of course,
you know, any other celebration. But I thought one month would be a good one.
After all, I did all you senpais. I did all you because I was going to do a hand cam and then
I had a huge rash.
And then I had a huge rash.
Yeah, the rash killed the original plan. I also went all over. I even went into the next town
to try to find like fishnets. They don't sell a lot of fishnets. So I had to, I had to get this
glove. So I hope that's okay senpai. Senpai. Wait, I heard birthday, happy birthday. It's not my
birthday. I said we'll celebrate again when it is my birthday.
Also, do you not know my birthday senpai?
Sounds like it's tripped to Spencer's. I don't think Spencer's had any either.
No, we know. Uh-huh, what is it then?
Huh? Yeah, yeah, it's when Julius Caesar died. Whoa.
Call. Senpai. Shut up. It's not my birthday.
Welcome back, Abby.
Stop it, stop it senpai. It's not my birthday.
It's not even, unless you're doing like a very merry-on birthday to me, to me.
A very merry-on birthday to you, to who, to me, to you.
Senpai, senpai. Thank you for 1-9-9, happy nop-
Okay, fine. I mean, there's cake and celebrating. It seems like a birthday.
Do you not want to celebrate? You don't want to celebrate our one month together? That's a
milestone, right? In relationships. Thank you, we suck at this.
Happy birthday, Abby. Boy says happy Canada Day. Yeah, that's true.
I'm so tired senpai though. I'm probably gonna fix this cough, maybe I'm actually coming down
with something. But thank you for joining me today. I hope you had a good one. I hope you liked my hands.
Senpai.
I gotta figure out how to take off these band-aids. By the way, this is my friend,
my gal pal came by and like gave me this and she's like, I lost my Naruto cosplay,
my broccoli cosplay, so I have these mummy raps you can use.
So yeah, thank you senpais for joining me today.
And no, I'm not injured, I'm cosplaying.
So thank you, peace.
Yeah, see you again. Wait, what's my schedule?
Give me a second senpai as I'm gonna check my schedule.
This is the wrong account. That is the wrong schedule.
Hold on. Okay, okay.
Tomorrow is the harvester finale. Yeah, we'll be finishing harvester, hopefully.
And then I'm on a break and then to Thursday is continuing Mario RPG. Yeah.
And then after that is members only stream SMP Nocturne. Yeah.
And then after that is a collab with my bestie Serenity Cosmica from VNU and we're going to play
Takoyaki party. Yeah.
So I hope you guys are will be there for the rest of this week and I'll see you again next time.
Okay, screen for mercy. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.